а ріні всього два з половиною роки вона
багато грається і сміється проте в очі
одразу впадає катетер на її маленький
руці спочатку діагностувати захворювання
не вдалося а вже за місяць почалося
повномасштабне вторгнення і її сім'я
опинилася під постійними обстрілами в
Миколаєві ми спускалися по-перше
підвал або були постійні і ці смерті і
Гради Миколаїв кожен день австрілювали а
потім ми вирішили
евакуюватися в Румунію бо моя фірма
почала вивозити жінок та дітей у Румунії
дитині стало гірше больовий синдром
постійно по ночам вони і були вживотик
будучи вже в Румунії Ми там зверталися
по швидкій навіть декілька разів нічого
не виявляли тоді сім'я повернулася в
Україну і об’їздила різні лікарні
Закарпаття поки Аріні не поставили
страшний діагноз рак пухлина була
розташована біля хребта тому видалити її
було дуже складно за лікування дівчинки
взялися лікарі спеціалізованого дитячого
медичного центру у Львові в Миколаєві
залишитись без медичного догляду в той
час коли обстріли Це було дуже страшно і
складно
і то що ми повернулись на Україну а не
залишились там за кордоном це
зберегло життя
бо Саме тут ми знайшли
порятунок і тут нас почали лікувати саме
ця лікарня від початку уповномасштабного
вторгнення стала опорним центром та
евакуаційним хабом для важкохворих дітей
з усієї України через постійні обстріли
зачинені радіологічні центри та склади з
медпостачанням онкохворих сюди вивозили
цілими відділеннями а логістику
організував благодійний фонд таблеточки
ми там і укрзалізницю залучали
Міністерство охорони здоров'я залучали і
першу Ладі і депутатів і якихось просто
бізнесменів наших донорів спонсорів Хто
готовий був надати якийсь транспортний
засіб бажано з охороною для того щоб ціх
дітей без затримки до вас до Львова
і там їх приймали там їх обстежували
госпіталізували нормалізували їхній стан
бо діти після перебування в
бомбосховищах в різних умовах вони там
хто гарячкував хто потребував свою
переливання крові хто перебував
антибактеріальної терапії антивірус
терапії ну тобто
лікарям було багато роботи так сюди
потрапив і чотирирічний Богданчик якого
батьки вивезли з окупованого Мелітополя
коли вже
зайшли ці рашисти
наш населений пункт То він вже все було
відрізано тобто
лікарні лікарі вже Бойко ну знаєте і в
той час ми замітили що Богданчика він
якось так почав дивитися
телевізор не так як він раніше і ліве
око стало не таке як правило воно почало
просто знаєте як вилазити саме ну саме
яблучко вилазити ми прийшли обстеження в
Запоріжжі в нас знайшли велику пухлину в
нас керували в Одесу в клініку Філатова
там зробили операцію хлопчику і
аналіз показав що то раптоміосаркома
дуже ну знаєте дуже така
дуже тоді сина терміново повезли у Львів
У цьому медцентрі Богданчик провів вже
понад рік
А зараз вже трошки краще себе почуваєш
Я таку відношення як
лікарів
Я на них Я на них кажу боги вони дійсно
дуже нам допомагають без них вже нічого
не було ми приїхали пройшли лікування 9
хімії вилікувалося все було добре потім
я не знаю від чого чи від стресу знову і
знову знайшли пухлину І от е-е травня
місяця бананчика знову пропарували
лікарня працювала у посиленому режимі
24/7 і допомогла сотням важкохворих
діток потік був просто величезним тому
частину з них відправляли лікуватися за
кордон щоб на їхнє місце могла приїхати
Нова хвиля пацієнтів з окупованих чи при
фронтових територій ми не могли
справитися з такою кількістю дітей нас
іноді поступало з по 100 дітей за
важкохворих за день розумієте так це Ну
це я думаю нью-йоркська лікарня
насправді то що ми зробили ми по суті з
координували величезну міжнародну мережу
дитячих лікарень онкохворих онкологічних
яким приймали цих дітей Це все було
скоординовано всі вони мали переклад
своїх виписок була координація між
українськими лікарями та іноземними і це
все було безкоштовно для тих пацієнтів
допомогла у цьому американська лікарня
сендю Children's reserich Hospital яка
розгорнула мережу розподілу українських
дітей серед європейських і
північноамериканських клінік у цій
ініціативі взяли участь 19 країн Польщі
Німеччина Італія Нідерланди США Канада
та багато інших Таким чином вдалося
евакуювати понад півтори тисячі
важкохворих пацієнтів разом із сім'ями
останній номер в реєстрі який я бачив за
1506 Зрозуміло так тепер ясно кожен
наступний присвоюється номер це
неймовірна кількість тим більше ніж за
рік нових випадків виникає в Україні в
цьому проекті ми не просто дітей
вивозили адже їхніх членів сімей і тому
загальна кількість людей яким ми
допомогли вони вивозили їх якимось
нещасними автобусами ми вивозили
медичним транспортом в супроводі ні
вертольоти іноді медичний військовий
потяг натівський приїжджав до Шегині то
медики
це
понад 3000 їхніх членів сімей також
зараз кількість дітей яких евакуйовують
за кордон зменшилася максимум 5-7 на
тиждень та лікарня все одно заповнена
пацієнтів насправді дуже збільшилось
пацієнти ну крім того що вони всієї
України вони але й загалом їх
збільшилося в нас наприклад зараз це ну
близько 25 пацієнтів і двоє з них
дорослих хлопців які можуть отримувати
лікування в амбулаторному режимі хоча
Колись ми такого ніколи не робили але
зараз ми мусимо переходити на такі
режими бо всі його треба отримувати
лікування ми влаштовуємося під кожну
ситуацію і окремо комусь капаємо тільки
вдень хімію на ніч відпускаємо додому а
на другий день не приходять і далі Ми
продовжуємо інфузії тому що всі палати
зайняті немає вільного ліжка наш потік
пацієнтів зрізав двічі через те що крім
зовнішньої міграції якщо внутрішня
міграція відповідно кількість
важкохворих дітей яких ми лікуємо зросла
вдвічі кількість нашого штату також
серйозна щоб це все отримати і ліки всі
ми отримуємо і від держави нашої і від
наших закордонних партнерів і від всяких
міжнародних проектів тут у нас є кілька
джерел на всяк випадок якщо одне з
джерел припиниться то його підстрахує
друге
хворих діток в Україні стало складніше
кажуть У фонді таблеточки в Україні
зараз більшість наш традиційних донорів
вони є або не платоспроможні або Вони
зараз переключилися на фінансування
інших потреб ну таких як безпеку армія І
так далі І звісно дитячу онкологія як як
така хронічна проблема да вона відходить
на другий план але вона для нас не
відходить на другий план бо це наша
місія займатися цим питанням дитячі рак
нікуди не зник війна його не відмінила
війна не поставила його на паузу Тому
тепер доводиться шукати інші джерела
допомоги переважно іноземні щоб
продовжити рятувати маленьких пацієнтів